this is floating passively combat art
that's given to you by pot noble Haru
Naga a carp scales vendor to the right
of the herati Estates bridge and I
bought it so that you don't have to it's
pretty bad large enemies will just poise
through this long animation and it
achieves less than whirlwind strike
which also offers a cleave effect let me
know if I'm missing something
Haru Naga also offers a mask fragment
and I'm sure many of you are wondering
if it's worth investing in if you find
all three of these then you receive the
dancing dragon mask a key item that
allows you to exchange five skill points
to increase your attack power by one
it's something that you're probably more
likely to make use of in the late game
something you can use in this level
though is the withered red gourd it
restores when you sit upon fires just
like your other one and this one removes
fire build-up which is something you're
gonna need when you stand in this fire
along the estate path this is where
you'll find the flame barrel which is an
essential prosthetic weapon and most of
you probably found it but did you know
that there's actually a really rare
piece of dialogue that you can receive
here you have to stealth close to these
soldiers without being seen which is not
an easy task considering how many Scouts
there are in this little tiny section
nearby the carp scales men are a couple
of boats that some bandits likely used
to come ashore and reinforcing that
theory is an item that's left behind on
those boats a mibu possession balloon
which increases item drop from killing
enemies which is obviously something you
could imagine a bunch of pillaging
bandits using across the way is anna
yama a talkative bandit who's set on
looting the place this explains why he
has lady butterflies phantom kunai later
in the game he speaks of some three
story pagoda up on some cliff which is a
tip that can lead you to a really really
well-hidden prosthetic weapon I didn't
find this on my first plate
so to find this you take the first left
on the bamboo thicket slow and then you
follow the river until you reach this
outcrop break through the old bamboo
door jump the walls up the mountain and
you'll face a purple cloak which is a
really tough enemy this early in the
game so this guy is one of seventeen
lone shadows these are agents from the
interior ministry and this one is
sitting and watching from his high perch
while the bandits do all of their dirty
work you can beat him by getting good
with your sheer skill you can beat him
in a lame way by running back down the
mountain then going back up again and
killing him in stealth or you can use
von teese patented ankle chipping
technique whatever you choose open the
pagoda and you'll be able to loot the
mist Ravens feathers which is the
prosthetic that's really powerful
against enemies that have really slow
heavy hitting attacks allowing you to
get in a lot of health damage from
behind the final prosthetic weapon
hidden in the estates is the loaded axe
and you're clued in to its location by
this man on the estate path who is
furious about the bandit invasion he's
one of many bodies in this area that
addressed in this blue garb and it
likely marks him as one of the high
ranking warriors of the Hirata two other
living men wear this same garb and both
of them claim to be from the Nogami
family which was a vassal family of the
Hirata whose Hirata estates are under
attack from these bandits and the errata
themselves are a vassal to the escena
who are pretty much as high as it goes
in this region although the escena are
rapidly losing influence anyway the
first confirmed member of the family
that we meet is Naga Meighan say as he
lets you know he fought with the escena
when they claimed this land explaining
his fierce loyalty to eachine of the
escena and also the divine prince who he
has been tasked with protecting if he
dies in the fight against juzo one of
the bandits he laments his failure to
Lord Kuro but if he survives the fight
against Jews oh this is what he says
or 10 you are what are you Ray
zucchini okay and if you kill him
afterwards you cement yourself in his
eyes as a rogue shinobi without a family
name and without honor it's not too
wrong honestly the reason so many people
here call us a rogue shinobi is likely
because we were nowhere to be seen when
the bandits attacked despite already
being the princes shinobi so this is
common knowledge among the town and
especially amongst the Nogami family who
pretty much all call you a rogue but I
wonder and I don't know if anyone has
this answer but where were we
during this attack on the Hirata estates
who lured us away the mother of a couple
of the Nogami men cow was inside this
scared maid will one day become one of
many afflicted by your dragon rot and
considering Emma talks often about the
overflow that's associated with dragon
rot this scared maid appears to be
traumatized by a vision of what's to
come
to rescue him
this is Nogami inosuke a man who has
barely survived his fight with Lady
butterfly if you look closely at him you
can see he actually has blood streaming
down from both of his eyes which i think
has to do with the illusions that he's
seen undoubtedly he saw something
terrible right and maybe he clawed his
own eyes out or she made him claw his
own eyes out
as a way of escaping these illusions
which is why I think it's actually a bit
of a missed opportunity to not have
these illusions mean something
devastating to sec you know instead from
what I can tell they're just laborers
with a sort of headscarf
which might mean something it's probably
more likely that they have to do with
Lady butterfly herself of course this
man is the exact same Naga me you know
sky we find in the escena outskirts
three years later which explains now why
he had those bands fully wrapped over
his eyes he was permanently crippled all
those years ago
in the Hirata estates and now he has the
lone task of looking after his mother
now that we recognized that he was blind
all this time it explains why he says he
remembers our voice his mother of course
is the one that gave us the Bell and
maybe it was her desire to help the
prince that sort of linked us back to
the Hirata estates recreating this
memory with Buddha's help before you go
and die - lady butterfly a bunch of
times now in the first episode is a
really good time to tell you that not
all shinobi walls actually have a human
shape clearly revealing them Scrolls -
are something to look out for because
they often hide some seriously good loot
in me boo balloon of wealth divine
confetti a light coin purse and most
importantly the prayer bead as you run
towards lady butterfly again and again
like I did spare a thought for this one
enemy who has the worst recurring
nightmare in the history of the Soul
series if you're wondering though there
is a reason he's here and it's because
from software knows how hard this fight
is and having him here allows you to
refill your second
resurrection bar on your way back to
lady butterfly Thank You Bo bandit as
you fight all of the mini bosses and
bosses in this area remember most bosses
actually come with a really significant
prosthetic weakness lady butterfly for
example can be knocked off her wires
with sugar cones and your spirit emblems
can be restored in Phase two by killing
her illusions juzo is weak to the faded
al feather as he has really slow attacks
and he's also a great candidate to light
on fire he's so slow and big that he's
really easy to hit with oil urns which
allow you to set him on fire with one
flame charge instead of two this means
you can set him on fire a ton of times
throughout the fight and finally the
shinobi hunter he suffers against
firecrackers and shuriken use which
makes this difficult to fight a cakewalk
for most players after you defeat it
lady butterfly you awakened back at the
dilapidated temple however if you return
to a boss room there's actually an idol
here now that you can rest at it seems
like it serves no purpose but you can
sit here and use it to confront the
memory of lady butterfly and you'll
learn a little bit more of our history
with her long ago
owl actually appointed her to teach us
shinobi techniques and they were not
teachings of a kind sort now later in
the game it's possible to return to the
Hirata estates and the two tips that are
gonna follow relate to this area I want
to warn you do not watch any further
unless you have fought the second boss
battle atop escena castle I will be
spoiling who stabs you from behind after
defeating lady butterfly and it's a
major plot point in the game the perfect
get away from this video is my merged
link quick get out of here 14 the sword
that stabs you from behind is a long
thick blade and it's assumedly not easy
to sneak up on a shinobi unless of
course you're a master shinobi the
person who stabs us from behind is our
Father the
the owl is the master of the shinobi
tree and he uses a ton of techniques
that we ourselves have access to first
mckiddy used on you when you initiate
with a charge step which I do way too
often a second he uses shadow brush
which is the combat art at the end of
the shinobi skill tree he also uses
distractions like firecrackers sugar
cones and a spirit that flies around the
room that you have to keep an eye on he
also has a bunch of feint attacks that
trick you into thinking he's gonna do
one thing when he does another this boss
is incredible from a design perspective
if you're wondering why he's more
difficult here it's also because he's
three years younger than the easier hour
that you encounter later atop machinae
castle so the owl was the one who
arranged this whole rebellion and he
coordinated with the interior ministry
which are these purple closed guys to do
so this is why you see one of those
purple cloaked guys all those years ago
in the first memory sitting atop the
three-tiered pagoda so why did he do
this well perhaps he wished to have you
killed and make the prince loyal to him
instead perhaps he wanted to force the
Prince to bestow the dragon's heritage
upon you his loyal son but as we
uncovered the secrets of secular we'll
get back to this I promise
for now subscribe click the bell to be
notified of new videos and I'll see you
next time